After an endless series of delays and reshoots,
Aquaman will get his second solo film just in
time for Christmas. Before you dive in, here
is what you need to know before its premiere.
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" is slated for
release on December 22, 2023. Fans who have
been following the DC Extended Universe will
know that "Lost Kingdom" suffered some drastic
delays due to the shakeup that occurred following
the Warner Bros. Discovery merger. The movie was
initially scheduled to be released on December
16, 2022, before being moved back to March 17,
2023. The film was moved yet again to
December 25, 2023, and then to December 20.
Finally, Warner Bros. decided to move
the film one more time to December 22,
which is where it'll hopefully stay put.
December will be a big month for the studio,
as they're releasing "Wonka," "Aquaman," and
"The Color Purple" back to back to back. Will
their three-pronged play bring in the box office
dollars? The movies likely won't be competing
for the same audiences, so if fans are in the
mood for superhero action during the holidays,
"The Last Kingdom" might fare well
against its December competition.
As fans might recall, the first "Aquaman" saw our
hero defeat his half-brother, Orm, and take over
as king of Atlantis. According to the official
synopsis, Aquaman's new reign comes under attack
after his old enemy, Black Manta, arrives in
Atlantis seeking revenge. This time though,
the villain has the power of the Black Trident
which unleashes a devastating and evil power.
Following the return of Black Manta,
Aquaman is forced to team up with his
imprisoned brother as the two try desperately
to save their family's kingdom and the world
from the destructive power of the Black
Trident. With these two brothers bickering,
it's sure to be a blast as they battle all sorts
of aquatic enemies to protect their homeworld.
"Good job, little brother. High five."
"Do not call me brother."
"Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom" stars Jason Momoa
as the Atlantean king, who also goes by the name
of Arthur Curry. Yahya Abdul-Mateen II and Patrick
Wilson reprise their roles from the first film as
well, with Temeura Morrison and Nicole Kidman
also returning to play Tom Curry and Atlanna.
Also returning to the cast is Amber Heard, who
reprises her role as the Atlantean warrior Mera.
Heard's involvement with the film continues to be
a source of heavy controversy among online fans,
with many still petitioning for her removal
from "Aquaman" after she lost a civil defamation
verdict against Johnny Depp in 2022. Heard
is joined by action star Dolph Lundgren,
who is set to appear in the film
as Mera's father, King Nereus.
When the original "Aquaman" swam into theaters
back in 2018, the undersea adventure earned a
staggering $1.14 billion, which made
it the fifth highest-grossing movie
of the year. Needless to say, Warner Bros.
didn't want to screw around with success,
so they brought on the same filmmaker who sailed
the original movie to box office glory: James Wan.
In addition to helming both "Aquaman" movies, Wan
is no stranger to action fare, as he directed both
"Furious 7" and "Death Sentence." Of course, most
moviegoers probably associate Wan with the horror
genre, as he also directed "Saw," "The Conjuring,"
and "Insidious," among other creepy films. And
evidently, he had his fair share of horror working
on "The Lost Kingdom," as Wan had to undergo three
separate reshoots, which The Hollywood Reporter
described as "almost an unprecedented number."
Warner Bros. and DC have famously undergone
some regime changes over the last few years,
and evidently, new bosses demanded new angles on
the material. Despite all the behind-the-scenes
drama, Wan got it done, and even though
multiple people have given him notes,
the filmmaker insists "The Lost
Kingdom" is still his creation,
telling Entertainment Weekly, "At the
end of the day, this is my movie."
In addition to bringing back Jason
Momoa and James Wan for the sequel,
the film also features the return of
screenwriter David Leslie Johnson-McGoldrick,
a longtime collaborator of Wan's and the
writer behind the original "Aquaman" film.
"Are you invoking the Combat of the Kings?"
"Call it whatever you want.
I call it an ass whoopin'."
Aside from "Lost Kingdom," Johnson-McGoldrick
has also written screenplays for films like
"Wrath of the Titans," and "The Conjuring 2" and
television shows like "The Walking Dead." Early
reports indicated that at least some of the
story for "Lost Kingdom" was based on a pitch
that Momoa himself created after the filming of
the first "Aquaman." However, as of right now,
it's unclear how much of that pitch made
it into Johnson-McGoldrick's final script.
While there have been a few exceptions here and
there, such as the R-rated "Zack Snyder's Justice
League," most DCEU movies come ready to rock with
a PG-13 rating. After all, it's the sweet spot for
blockbuster success. It's just edgy enough so you
know there's some violence and mild cursing, but
it's tame enough so kids and teens can watch. All
the highest-grossing movies are PG-13, and that's
also true for DC titles such as "Wonder Woman,"
"Man of Steel," and the original "Aquaman."
So it should come as no surprise
that "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
will be rated PG-13. The aquatic adventure
earned that rating due to "sci-fi violence
and some language." Expect the same sort of
content you saw in the first "Aquaman" film,
and chances are good that you won't be
shocked by anything you see on the screen.
After the film's title announcement earlier
that month, production for "Aquaman and the Lost
Kingdom" began in late June 2021. While the first
film was shot in Australia, Italy, and Morocco,
"The Lost Kingdom" began production in the
United Kingdom where most of the film was shot.
With so much of "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
taking place underwater, it makes sense that the
picture would be shot at Warner Bros. Studios in
London, something that fans taking the studio tour
confirmed back in July 2022. Though principal
photography had wrapped six months earlier,
additional reshoots with Ben Affleck's
Batman took place in the summer of 2022.
Beyond Europe, "The Lost Kingdom" spent some
time in the United States. Throughout the back
half of 2021, Los Angeles and Hawaiian units
shot additional material, with lead stars Jason
Momoa and Patrick Wilson seen on set in Malibu
on the very last day of principal photography.
Most comic book and superhero movies are
generally inspired by the source material, so
it shouldn't come as a surprise that "Aquaman and
the Lost Kingdom" draws from those same sources.
At the end of the trailer for the movie,
Warner Bros. and DC Comics promoted a few
graphic novels that showcase the recent
history of our favorite Atlantian king.
"The Trench" and "War for the Throne" are both
stories written by DC scribe Geoff Johns when he
reinvented Aquaman for a modern audience. The
third book, "The Drowning," was helmed by Dan
Abnett and set during the "DC Rebirth" era,
which sought to combine the traditional DC
status quo with modern stories in a blended
universe. "The Drowning" is also notable due
to Arthur's attempts to make peace between
his undersea people and the surface world.
Of course, these aren't the only Aquaman stories
that likely inspired "The Lost Kingdom," but given
that they're being officially promoted by the
film, there's probably a strong correlation.
It's no secret that the DC Extended
Universe timeline is a bit of a mess.
Despite starting strong with a clear vision
for a more mature take on the franchise,
everything after "Justice League" feels
pretty disjointed. Not even Zack Snyder's
long-anticipated director's cut of "Justice
League" could fix the DCEU, leaving its
fate up in the air until James Gunn and Peter
Safran took over in 2023 and axed it for good.
Following "Man of Steel" was "Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice" in 2016,
which marked the first tease of Jason
Momoa's Aquaman, and the following year
brought "Justice League." After that, the
Atlantian got his own feature film in 2018,
which is set about a year after Steppenwolf
attacked Earth and the Justice League was
formed. In the years following, the DCEU
opted to highlight characters such as Shazam,
Harley Quinn, and Peacemaker in a variety
of projects leading into the 2020s.
Taking place around the events of 2022's
"Black Adam" and 2023’s "Shazam! Fury of
the Gods," and possibly after "The Flash,"
the "Aquaman" sequel continues Arthur's
story as the DCEU closes shop. Where "Blue
Beetle" fits into all this, we don't know,
but we know that "The Lost Kingdom"
marks the official end of the DCEU.
After his brief "found footage" cameo in
"Batman v Superman: Dawn of Justice," Jason
Momoa made his first official appearance in 2017's
"Justice League." When Batman first meets him,
Arthur is disillusioned and depressed,
having been cast out by his own people.
"Strong man is strongest
alone. You ever heard that?"
"That's not a saying. That's the opposite of what
the saying is."
"Yup."
It's only after meeting others
like him and saving the world
that he sees the value in being a hero and a king.
A year later, Arthur is confronted by
Mera and Vulko, who need his help to
save Atlantis. Arthur's half-brother Orm
is quickly running the kingdom into the
ground and aims to declare war on the
surface world. This leads to Arthur and
Mera discovering the Trident of Atlan, finding
his mother Atlanna, and reclaiming the throne
after defeating Orm. "Aquaman" ends with
Arthur now ruling as the king of Atlantis.
Unfortunately, Aquaman doesn't appear much in the
DCEU after that. He's mentioned here or there in
movies like "Shazam!," but it wasn't until a cameo
in the Season 1 finale of "Peacemaker" that Momoa
returned to the role, alongside Ezra Miller's
Flash. Speaking of, Arthur drunkenly reunites
with Barry Allen at the end of "The Flash" too,
which is fitting given how that movie wraps up.
Before James Gunn and Peter Safran opted
against saving the DCEU, the franchise was
going in a very different direction. Following
his turn in "The Flash," Michael Keaton's Batman
was set to appear in "Aquaman 2," as well
as in the now-scrapped "Batgirl" movie.
But other plans were made. There was a
time when "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
was meant to premiere before the events
of "The Flash," and because of that,
reshoots were made to replace Keaton's cameo with
Ben Affleck's version of the character. Of course,
fans were excited by the news, and many had hope
that the DCEU was about to find its footing again,
especially after Henry Cavill's
way-too-brief return as Superman
at the end of "Black Adam." And
then Gunn and Safran came in.
DC Films became DC Studios, and the DCEU was
retconned in favor of the upcoming DC Universe,
which aims to reboot the live-action franchise
anew with a brand new Batman and Superman.
Needless to say, Batman's cameo — be it
Affleck or Keaton — is deep underwater.
In the first "Aquaman," we learn
all about young Arthur's journey
to becoming the man who eventually helps
save the world and unite the kingdoms of
Atlantis. Invaluable in his formation from a
troubled youth to kingly material is Vulko,
who watches out for Arthur throughout
his whole life. Vulko makes his first
official DCEU appearance in "Aquaman,"
where he helps Arthur take the throne.
Fans may be disappointed to learn that Willem
Dafoe won't be returning as Vulko in "Aquaman 2,"
though it's not because he's off playing the Green
Goblin for Marvel again. According to director
James Wan, Vulko's absence is due to a scheduling
conflict. Wan revealed to Entertainment Weekly,
"Part of the reason was because [Dafoe's] schedule
did not work out for us, but what that allowed me
to do was expand on Atlanna's role. Atlanna in
this one ultimately becomes Arthur's advisor."
Traditionally, Vulko serves as Aquaman's
faithful advisor in the world of DC Comics,
but here on the screen, it seems that Nichole
Kidman's Atlanna will fill that role instead.
It's fitting, though, and allows Arthur
and his mother the much-needed face time
that they've been deprived of for so long.
Still, it's sad we won't see Dafoe return.
In the first "Aquaman," it's revealed that there
are seven kingdoms of Atlantis. As its king,
Arthur's quest to unite them is
near the top of his to-do list,
but we're a bit fuzzy on what the
seventh kingdom might actually be.
"The Lost Nation had not yet vanished. Together,
they were the greatest empire
the world had ever seen."
Of course, there's Atlantis itself,
and we soon learn of the others,
which include Xebel, the Kingdom of the Fishermen,
the Kingdom of the Brine, the Kingdom of
the Deserters, and the monstrous Trench.
Though Atlantis, Xebel, the Trench, and the
Deserters were all addressed in the DC continuity
before the 2018 film, the comic book versions of
the final three kingdoms weren't revealed until
afterward in the "Echoes of A Life Lived Well"
arc. The Brine is the first, being transplanted
into the comics from the DCEU, and the Kingdom
of the Wrights and the Kingdom of the Sea Lights
followed. The Wrights are a bunch of underwater
rodents, while the Sea Lights are strange
bioluminescent humanoids. More than likely, the
film will take a completely different approach.
In the trailer for "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom,"
Arthur and Mera are married, and they have a son
of their own. This begs the question if what
we see in "The Lost Kingdom" is in line with
what happens in the comics. Like anything that
deals with Aquaman's comic book history, it's
somewhat complicated, but there are clear answers.
In 1965, "Aquaman #23" hit stores, and "Aquababy"
was born. That was the actual nickname for Arthur
Curry, Jr., the firstborn son of Aquaman and Mera.
Unfortunately, the happy family didn't stay happy
forever. In "Adventure Comics #452," Aquaman and
Aqualad are forced into a battle to the death
by Black Manta, who uses young Arthur Jr. as
leverage. As expected, Aquaman defeats Manta, but
at a terrible price. His son is ultimately killed
by the supervillain, suffocating as a result
of his captivity. This drove a wedge between
Aquaman and Mera for decades. Eventually, though,
they're able to rekindle and save their marriage.
Aquaman has other children too. Aqualad,
later known as Tempest was considered
Aquaman and Mera's adopted son, while
A.J. was their second child together
years later. Arthur also had a child named
Koryak with an Inuit woman at some point,
and in the current DC Rebirth continuity, Aquaman
and Mera only have a daughter named Andrina.
Also appearing in the trailer for "Aquaman and the
Lost Kingdom" is Black Manta, who swore vengeance
on Aquaman back in the first movie after the
superhero refused to save his dying father. Of
course, the comic book version of their rivalry
is much darker than that, with Aquaman purposely
killing Manta's father in revenge following his
own father's death. Additionally, recent comics
have revealed that Manta is actually a long-lost
descendant of the Kingdom of the Deserters.
In the DCEU, however, Manta seems to
be completely human, which puts him at
a significant disadvantage when facing off
against a superhero like Aquaman. Therefore,
using Atlantean technology gifted to him by
Ocean Master, Manta has sworn revenge on his
adversary. But this time around, Black Manta's
abilities have been upgraded through the use of
the previously unseen Black Trident. This
magical artifact originates from the time
of the first King Atlan and seems to give
the one who wields it incredible powers.
Though it's unlikely a direct adaptation
of either, this new Black Trident seems
to borrow from two different weapons
from Aquaman's comic book adventures:
the Trident of Triton and the Dead King's
Scepter. Triton's trident simply directed
the Olympian's power, while the Dead King's
Scepter gave the user control of the sea.
From what we see of the Black Trident in
the trailer, it may even unleash the dead.
Despite being mentioned elsewhere
in the "Aquaman 2" trailer,
Mera only appears once in the entire thing,
with a brief glimpse at her as she attempts
to break into some sort of underwater craft.
While it might be easy to immediately blame
her lack of screen time in the trailer,
and possibly the finished film as well,
on the recent and very public defamation trial
between Amber Heard and her ex-husband Johnny
Depp, that might not be the full story. Warner
Bros. executive Walter Hamada said in 2022,
"[Jason Momoa and Amber Heard] didn't really
have a lot of chemistry together. The reality is,
it's not uncommon on movies for
two leads to not have chemistry."
"Your majesty, there is no victory in defeating
the ignorant. Your brother
is clearly an imbecile."
Hamada added that a lot of their "chemistry"
was developed off-set during post-production,
making us wonder how much Mera will appear in
"The Lost Kingdom" at all. But, according to
director James Wan, this was always the plan for
the sequel. He explained to Entertainment Weekly,
"I always pitched this to everyone from the
get-go. The first 'Aquaman' was Arthur and
Mera's journey. The second movie was always
going to be Arthur and Orm. So, the first was
a romance action-adventure movie, the second
one is a bromance action-adventure movie."
A modern master of horror, Wan rose to
international acclaim when he co-created
and directed the first "Saw" back in 2004.
The film was so popular that a sequel was
greenlit every year for the next six years
until "Saw 3D" in 2010. But even then,
Wan's time with the genre had only just begun.
In 2010, Wan directed the first "Insidious,"
which starred future "Aquaman" actor Patrick
Wilson and spawned a plethora of
sequels. A few years later in 2013,
Wan directed "The Conjuring," which likewise
sparked an entire cinematic universe. Since then,
he's worked on several other horror movies,
including 2021's "Malignant." No wonder Wan
used his trademark horror techniques during
the Trench sequence in the first "Aquaman."
So when the trailer for "The Lost Kingdom"
shows an undead army controlled by Black Manta,
it's no wonder Wan admitted to adding a certain
horror flare back into the sequel.
He said at 2020's DC Fandome event,
"Just like the first movie had a touch of my
horror sensibility, you know, in regards to
the Trench sequence, I would say there will
be a little bit of that in this next one."
Following the release of the first "Aquaman"
in 2018, James Wan announced the development
of a horror-infused spin-off centered around the
Trench. These sea-dwelling beasts first appeared
in Geoff Johns' "Aquaman" run during the "New 52"
rebrand, and they've since risen to popularity
after appearing in the first film. Producer
Peter Safran told The Hollywood Reporter in 2019,
"We always, even from the early concept art
days, loved the idea of a 'Trench' movie."
He revealed that "The Trench" was meant
to arrive in theaters before "Aquaman
and the Lost Kingdom." But only two years later,
Walter Hamada shook things up with the DC brand,
axing the project. While that was disappointing
news in and of itself, fans became even more
disillusioned after Wan commented further that
October. While showcasing Black Manta's new
look for "The Lost Kingdom," on Instagram
James Wan revealed something interesting,
"I'll let you in on a secret, the
canceled Trench spin-off movie was
really going to be a secret Black Manta movie."
No doubt, fans of the DC supervillain
were floored by this news,
which only proves that Wan had even
bigger plans for the character and
the greater Aqua-verse. It's too bad the
same couldn't be said about Warner Bros.
With the news that both Batman and Superman would
be recast for the DC Universe reboot and reports
that Gal Gadot likely isn't returning as
Wonder Woman, it's understandable that
fans would wonder about the fate of Jason
Momoa's Aquaman. With DC's biggest hitters
being tossed to the wayside in favor of new,
updated models, chances are that the beloved
King of Atlantis will be next. "The Flash" may
have kept Ezra Miller's Barry Allen and Jason
Momoa's Arthur Curry around for now, but things
could quickly change. At least in Momoa's eyes,
there won't be another Aquaman in the near future.
Speaking with Variety in 2023, following the news
of James Gunn and Peter Safran's intention
to reboot the movie universe, he said,
"I'll always be Aquaman. Ain't anyone coming
in there and taking s---. There might be some
other characters, too. I can play other things,
too. I can be funny and savage and charming."
With rumors swirling that Momoa is slated to
appear as Lobo in some point in the
near future, Peter Safran told io9,
"Jason always thought Aquaman was a trilogy, in
his own mind, but he also loves Lobo. He's been
very clear about that, too. He's never
going to play two characters, but..."
James Gunn then interrupted Safran, saying,
"We'll figure it out after 'Aquaman 2.'" For
now, we'll just have to wait and see
what will become of Momoa's Aquaman.
One of the biggest questions on fans' minds
concerning "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
is whether it will get a follow-up of
its own. More than likely, that will
depend on how well the blockbuster
does in theaters this Christmas,
but that may not be the only competing factor.
In September of 2023, James Wan told Screen Rant,
"I'm aware of [the impending DCU reboot]. I mean,
I use the analogy that I'm living in a house
that's getting renovated, but the beauty about
Aquaman is that we've always designed these
two films to be within their own world."
Given Wan's confidence, it's possible that future
installments could go the way of Matt Reeves'
out-of-continuity project "The Batman." It could
be a viable way to keep Momoa around. But that
doesn't mean the horror-turned-superhero director
wants to go a third round in the ring. When asked
by Entertainment Weekly if he'd be interested
in doing a third "Aquaman" film, he said,
"Oh, buddy. I don't know. This film
has taken up so, so much of my life,
so much of my time, all I can think
about now is taking a long break."
One can hardly blame him. Production was
stalled because of the COVID-19 pandemic,
his Black Manta-centered spin-off
"The Trench" was canceled,
and the entire DCEU went up in flames. It's
entirely possible that this could be the end
of Aquaman's on-screen adventures,
though we certainly hope for more.
While James Wan might see his "Aquaman"
movies as their own thing apart from the
greater DCEU or DCU, it's clear that Warner
Bros. and the folks at DC Studios don't see
it the same way. When asked about
the four DC-related movies of 2023,
James Gunn explained how they'll fit
into his larger plans, revealing to io9,
"I think that we've gotten lucky with the next
four movies. We have 'Shazam,' which leads into
'Flash,' which resets everything, which then goes
into 'Blue Beetle,' which is totally disconnected,
[and that] goes into 'Aquaman,' which leads
into 'Superman,' our first big project."
How exactly "Aquaman and the Lost Kingdom"
connects to a movie like "Superman: Legacy" is
currently unknown. The Gunn-helmed reboot is meant
to propel the Man of Steel into a new universe
that also includes heroes such as Hawkgirl and
the Guy Gardner Green Lantern. If there were to
be another sequel, it's possible that it could
fit into Gunn's newly minted DCU, especially
if he wants this interpretation of Aquaman to
be a building block for his larger universe.
Of course, given how popular multiverses
are nowadays, there's always that avenue,
though it seems that Gunn wants to stay
away from other worlds for now. "Superman:
Legacy" will follow a younger
Superman in an even younger universe,
which makes one wonder how an
experienced Aquaman might fit in.